folks Joe D Roa here I am out on the
road doing those live shows all over the
place and uh let's folks Jo de R Roa
here I am out doing live shows all over
the place by myself not with the Pod
just alone solo doing my thing uh first
up November 9th New York New York I'm
doing a special show this is a selected
readings I'm going to be reading entries
for my audio book The Penthouse papers
so plus plus some other stuff I've had
published over the years uh that's for
the New York com Festival in New York
New York at the KGB bar on November 9th
November 11th Philadelphia PA theater of
the Living Arts almost sold out only a
few tickets left please come out to that
November 17th we're sold out Pittsburgh
PA at the bottle rocket November 18th
Buffalo New York theater at senica 1
again almost sold out buy your tickets
Please November 30th Denver Colorado at
the summit December 1st Phoenix Arizona
at the Crescent Ballroom December 3rd
Salt Lake City in Utah at the soundwell
and January 13th just announced New York
New York grar SE theater folks new hour
popping off at the grammar SE and all of
those other venues I just listed with
the exception of the KGB bar show that's
the only one that's not me doing I never
Promise You a Rose Garden I'm going to
be doing readings from the book at that
show and that show only Anyway come
check me out jod rosa.com for all the
show info and your ticket links and as
usual if you're in New York please
please please come see us at Joey roses
open 7 days a week at 11:30 a.m. every
day delicious sandwiches cheap drinks
come see us and if you want info about
the venue Joey roses nc.com what's up
guys real quick tour dates are on sale
right now at salvano comedy.com there's
a big Illinois run in November leading
up to my comedy special at the Vick in
Chicago on December 1st and 2nd the
second sold out as you guys I hopefully
know uh and so we edit two shows on the
first all will be taped and all all if
you have a ticket to any of those shows
you'll be eligible to win uh a flight
hotel and trip to the set of Impractical
Jokers I'm choosing one ticket out of
those four shows uh December 1st is
still on sale right now but it's going
fast savano comedy.com hope to see you
guys on the road taste buds they com to
the mic talking about the food they hate
talking about the food they like two
fools going to fight but only one food
can be right
TS folks welcome to t a s e buds uh s is
out uh a little under the weather at the
moment locked him in his room he went
inside and locked him in and I took over
CU I'm Ari shafir yeah
AR there's one thing you know about Ari
shafir is that I lock people in their
rooms to get in there yeah yeah it's my
show now you showed up on the last
episode naked I'm I was looking for a
different thing I'm sorry I was look
there was a Chinese place near here that
I wanted to like go into and they have a
strict dress code and I I'm I I do
apologize to the viewers to the people
of America I'm sorry that I got the
woman in the
room that's the first [__] she's seen in
years the uh the well anyway folks
listen speaking of nuts that's that's
that's yeah speaking of nuts we're
battling today uh Popcorn versus peanuts
we'll get to it uh AR's going to be team
popcorn I'm going to be team peanuts
we're battling as a snack and we all and
we included Ari in the poll just so you
know all flavors all flavors because you
know because especially with popcorn I
felt like people would go people would
either go well popcorn with what just
salt plain popcorn sucks what you put on
it it's or they go dude it's soaked in
butter how can you compete like you got
to you or caramel corn you got to all
Flor honey no rusted peanuts all of
these have to play into it you have to
it's like saying steak but you can't
salt it yeah exactly of course you can
so but by the way I will tell you this
what flavors of peanuts have yeah go
ahead tell me there's tons of flavors
now but but I'll tell you this I had I
bought popcorn uh recently I bought just
some microwave stuff you're doing better
thank you uh and I bought uh I don't
know dude I bought like some some
organic [__] brand of what popcorn
yeah which was fine I was like I just
was looking for one that didn't have a
lot of extra [__] in it yeah and it said
it was called the flavor was called
simply
salted yeah and dude when I tell you
this tasted like not a grain of salt
touched it it just tastes like plain
popcorn there's nothing worse on PL
popcorn sucks I'd rather eat the kernels
of uncooked corn oh those are good you
ever have that almost pops the leftover
the shake of of the snack world it's
good if it's got It's good if it's got
all the salt and stuff on it oh it's so
good yeah yeah yeah I do that I suck all
the salt and everything everything off
it but yeah dude like plain pop I mean
it's it's a birth effects of snacks and
yet part of our society don't throw me
away yes it's like you ever eat a rice
cake yeah I have eaten a rice cake it's
the it's the worst thing ever unless
it's dunked in Caramel yeah if you cover
with peanut butter and jelly and make a
sandwich out of it you really with rice
cakes is kind of like uh uh um
grapefruits you're really the grapefruit
is just a conduit for the sugar yeah
grapefruit if you don't put that that
processed sugar all over it I mean you
are in bed you doing or if you do not
squeeze it into a glass of tequila with
booze yeah it'll help just to cut booze
and that's
it it's really just getting it just
allowing you to drink Straight Tequila
and even when you cut it with booze you
you usually still have to throw in like
like I love a greyhound or whatever you
still probably got to throw in like
appol or something else like if you just
put gra juice in VOD you're like God
Almighty man do you ever do you ever
accidentally think you're drinking
orange juice and then you drink
grapefruit juice instead it makes you
want to [__] vomit yeah it looks so
good though when it's pink so good it
it's so allor it looks like lemonade
that's what you get it most mixed up
with lemonade and then you're ready for
lemonade and then you drink really just
like rotted homeless [__] and then you're
just like I think here's the thing I
find non-pink grapefruit juice gross the
sight of it I mean because it looks like
biley to me it looks like it looks like
stomach air it's so acidic and then it's
that opaque yellow it looks like it you
puked it out of your stomach or
something it looks gross ruby red what a
way to call it's got to be ruby red but
that's the thing with grapefruit juice
dude if you go to a bar and you're
trying to watch your weight and you get
like a tequila soda with some grapefruit
you got to ask the bar you got to be
like is it real grapefruit juice because
if it's not they're just they might as
well be dumping so dude I did that in
the store I used to work there and I
would be like oh let me start switch
from Coca-Cola cuz you can just get the
gun and I'm like let me switch something
healthy to orange juice and I was drink
a lot of orange juice and like fibers
and stuff and people were just like
after like a year they're like that's
just sugar and that's not actual orange
yeah yeah and if you're not getting if
you're not getting like simply orange or
whatever they're dumping sugar into it
too so but even fresh squeezed orange
juice I remember Ali Wong explained this
to me I never knew this before she was
famous when she would still speak still
talk to
yeah she we totally cool I great I'm
just joking that's me making funun fer
can suck a
dick that's me making fun of me not
making fun of Ally yeah but she told me
when she still lived in San Francisco
that's where I became friends with her I
was like what's wrong with drinking
orange juice like what if it's fresh
Quee she goes dude it's like eating an
entire bag of oranges like she's like do
you understand you're eating you're
drinking the contents of like 10 oranges
in one glass so good it's so much sugar
like it doesn't matter if it's natural
sugar it's not good for you but it's
delicious yeah I think like I feel like
you're intentionally not getting to the
subject cuz you know peanuts suck no no
no I just like to kill a little time and
and you know sometimes you worry what if
the battle doesn't go long enough you
know yeah what
what were you going to say it doesn't
have legs no what were you going to say
nothing no talk mic what you going to
say speak around what you were going to
say fine you could talk I was just like
reacting to what you said it was funny
oh okay all right yeah why don't you put
the stuff at the end I like how you buy
time at the beginning let me tell you
run your show I like how you buy Time
Finance just did this in
case in case it doesn't go long instead
of just like well it went short now
let's just add stuff so so it's a fine
line you got to walk fine line if s's
here if s's here it's run right no if
s's
here s's here fortun you're back by way
if sh's here you might not even get to
the battle oh really we'll be 5 minutes
from the end and I'll be like why don't
we just save the battle for next time
like we have time babe it's fine we have
time you're like sh we're going to do a
three and a half minute battle right
now um anyway uh I am two and0 in battle
so far all right let's get into it let's
just get into it we'll we'll divert
throughout the whole thing I'm sure and
dig okay do you know the chant yeah oh
do you want to do the it's time to Sal
love you I love you we haven't done that
what what no matter what happens I love
you I don't I'd rather do the salty with
Ari okay we are salty we are sweet I am
salty he is sweet I am Ari he is Joe I
am salty he is sweet
so it's St it salty is I have a true
love forari I have a true love forari
and I I want to do the salty one with
him speaking of one R roads let's um so
you go so three times you go it's time
to get salty it's time to get salty it's
time to get salty yeah and then
immediately I fire an insult at you okay
and then we do it again time to get and
immediately you fire an insult at me and
the rule is you can't really retort it's
just you have to let it sit there and
live with it because it gets you in the
zone to like really go at each other
okay it works so how do you start it
again you I'll count to three and we go
it's time to get salty it's time to get
salty it's time to get salty and then
you fire an insult at me and then we do
it again and I fire one at you okay okay
okay ready yeah all right ready wa 1 2 3
it's time like that ready 1 2 3 it's
time to get salty it's time to get salty
it's time to get salty literally no New
York Comic has ever seen you go
[Laughter]
[Music]
up wow that
hurt that hurt I know you I know you
have there's like a grain of Truth in
that that hurt all right ready yeah uh
hold on let me
second uh okay ready yeah one two three
it's time to get salty it's time to get
salty it's time to get salty does it
ever get tired having to do all these
crazy stunts cuz the material can't
speak for
itself does that get exhausting after a
while ah I showed my dick again I'm
relevant oh I said a crazy thing about
Kobe why don't you try writing a
joke I was just a thought
anyway all right all right here we
go ready yep all right okay I'm I'm not
retarding no you're not allowed to you
could you could you could say something
about it to yourself okay like I said
wow that
hurts or if unless it didn't hurt I
don't think it did no I got to look at
my MDB of the specials I put out since
you put out your last one the uh that's
cool is true good material takes
time the uh I'm not rushing them out who
am I Sam morel
I'm going to shoot one of the next to
the plant at the comedy Celler this
week I'm kidding Sam I'm just joking now
one of the worst things happened to
stand up comedy was the ability just to
shoot one anytime like oh I'm I'm
waiting for the subway I as well shoot
one by the way you got it you got to say
you're just joking with Sam because he
will be like well dude I don't know man
I just think it's Sam well I wouldn't
think to insult
him all right we're going to have Sam on
the podcast too um okay time two you
know the battle CH battle battle okay
wait b a t t l e buds ready yeah time to
b a t t l e buds all right here we
go uh you're popcorn on Peanuts um
yes I will say
this I will start by saying I don't
think
that I think my snack just let's just
talk from a nutrition value well
nutritional value there's there's far
more nutritional benefits from peanuts
do have some sustenance to them there's
a benefit to them popcorn literally is
no no purpose like snacks in general
yeah okay but my point is is like it's
just Airy carbs that's all it is that's
literally FIB all it isib Airy fibers
fibers yes it's high in fiber is it yeah
popcorn dudee I've done a lot of
research in the Uber over here
okay popcorn is a Vari okay I also find
you Ari's very into
popcorn it's I find it to be the sign of
a of a deranged man
like like the fact that you you've told
me about this you have look I like
popcorn I eat popcorn I have multiple
ways of cooking it and yeah the only
reason I eat popcorn I told you before
we started was because you got me into
it yeah but yeah you have like popcorn
recipes and things it's weird it's like
something a person that lives on a
desolate Road does that then you bring
it to a table at a fair you sell your
you sell your popcorns to people it's
kind of weird it's a little weird yeah
okay fair but can I say could you go
back up and look at that thing look at
that down down now up now up a quarter
inch now down a quarter inch and now Ste
keep it there for a minute okay now I'm
done [__] with you so those things
peanuts and popcorns those are the best
way to eat them a street a street
immigrant with a shade listen I
absolutely agree with you but I'll tell
you this right now even in that scenario
popcorn peanuts have you beat because in
that scenario you're getting Hot Nuts
have you ever had warm nuts that's great
have you ever had warm
popcorn so great I never had warm nuts
till the first time I flew first class
and they put warm nuts down nice when
they warm it up for you and I was like I
was like I don't want any nuts and then
I reached and I was like oh my God and I
ate I was like where have you been all
my life like I finally understand like
in movies when I watch guys like buy
bags of warm nuts from a guy in the park
I'm like I never understood it then I
did it I was like oh my God let me tell
you this brings me to another uh one of
my points you had warm nuts which means
a variety of nuts when there's mixed
nuts they brag about how few peanuts
there are in the jar no they don't yes
they do they list you talking about
under a certain percent peanut because
You' go nuts with the cheapest most uh
uh easy to get nut in the world you
would just go wait a minute any mix nuts
they hold on I I need to see this I have
never seen this prove this to me mix
nuts percentage
peanuts mix nuts there you go less than
here it is less than 50% peanuts they
have to tell you or You' go nuts with
the cheapest nothing here we go is that
one less than certain percent peanuts
less than certain perc peanuts I I can't
hold on I can see wait pimp scroll up
again cuz your eyes aren't good popcorn
gives you good eyesight just click on
that second one the fancy unsalted mixed
nuts the second
picture just click on the
less than 50% peanuts look at there it
is look okay but do the pimp do the
second one I can see it on that one this
is the one where I can't see it see it
doesn't say it on there uned pimp extra
fancy there are no nuts it's already
said it's Fancy Go pimps go to the third
one Deluxe mix
nuts you know why they don't say it it's
cuz it's a ton of peanuts they can't I I
I have I have a theory about about that
okay first of all first of all it's
Planters yeah Planters is not they build
an Empire on the peanut dude I mean what
are you talking you're bragging about
how they don't show nuts look at who's
standing next to the thing mran the Mr
Peanut there is no Mr popcorn yes
they've built their empire on Peanuts
they're saying to you hey guys don't
think we're just laying back on what we
do here we're giving you something
here's the other thing about peanuts
peanuts are a legume and in a lot of
modern-day diets where that promote
corners of legum that that yes that that
promote nut intake or whatever yeah uh
that but they tell you to stay away from
peanuts because they're legumes and they
stick to your gut they give you gut
weight I think that's why that says less
than 50% whatever no it's because you go
too much they they go like 80% on the
shitty ones let's talk about mascots Mr
Peanut versus oral Redenbacher two Wares
of glasses W I didn't even dude that
actually would have been a battle in and
of itself oral versus Mr Peanut yeah but
look I'll quote the Pete Holmes joke
okay where and I'm going at Bas look at
that giant among men
so look at a that's a real human that
you associate with a snack Orville read
by a scientist who says you want
something high in fiber and low on
calories or you want to go to KFC again
Orville Redenbacher strangely looks like
and he was a scientist looks like a man
that in a horrible teleportation
accident was mixed with his DNA with the
peanut and became Mr Peanut he looks
like Mr Peanut he looks like in the
researching how how to how to best like
bait young children
to so Orville red at playing tennis he's
a man dude look how look at this guy
look how freaky this guy look he looks
like the preacher in in Poltergeist
too he looks like he's coming to your
door with salvation the uh look I'll
give you a few reasons why popcorn's
great Orville Redenbacher as far as the
human mascot is concerned you got
Orville Redenbacher they they just
started this show the it was Orville it
was Purdue and it was Wendy it was Dave
from
Wendy's I I will give you that that that
Orville is probably the all-time king of
human mascots yeah but you're not
messing with Mr Peanut dude you're not
messing with
Mr this is what I mean just stick to
your just stick to your
jokes what are you doing I'm a stun
man can you play the can you play the
Fall Guy theme right
there folks it may be too early to start
decorating for the holidays but it's
never too early to start shopping for
them so why not just take care of it now
before the crowds and the the pack
calendars and everything else makes
shopping A total nightmare forget all
that
rayon that's what that's the word I want
you to remember here rayon all right you
want a great deal you want a great gift
raycon products shop for them right now
and save up to 50% off because their
early Black Friday sale is going on now
now you've heard me talk about raycons
before uh I love the earbuds that
they're doing I I love them they sound
great the battery is longlasting 32h
hour battery life actually it's they've
got a perfect inar fit uh they uh are
easily uh syncable with your products
and they're just priced beautifully okay
this past year they expanded also raycon
has expanded their entire business what
else does raycon have going on all right
well they've got a five-star reviewed
magic 180 cable available now and that
the cable allows you to charge iOS micro
USB and type-c devices eight times
faster with 100 wat power delivery
they've also got a a faucet filter Ultra
that that Ultra filters your water in
your TAP against chlorine and and heavy
metals uh it's a must have for ensuring
the water you use to wash your face for
instance or brush your teeth is you know
actually clean anyway raycon is doing a
lot of really cool stuff they're doing
high quality stuff these are great
products uh and they're going to make
great gifts during this holiday season
so to get everyone in the holiday
shopping Spirit a bit early raycon is
currently offering 20% off everything on
their site with select products up to
50%
off hry now to buy raycon.com tastebuds
to get 20 to 50% off sitewide that's by
raycon bu y r a y n.com tastebuds to
score up to 50% off raycon products by
raycon.com tastebuds it's officially
time to Kickstart your holiday shopping
but there is no cause for panic people
why Uncommon Goods has your back they're
here to make your holiday shopping
stressfree by scouring the globe for the
most remarkable and truly unique gifts
for everyone on your list whether you're
shopping for Mom or Dad or brother or
sis teenagers in-laws old
young best friends acquaintances
whatever it is Uncommon Goods knows
exactly what they want here are just
some of the cool gifts they have uh just
to name a few here's a few uh favorite
gifts that I found on their website
these are the Christmas theme uh
category they they've got them all
categorized on the site and there's
actually Christmas category which is
convenient anyway uh they've got uh some
really cool wall art uh they've got a
pet Christmas sweater for your favorite
pet uh they've got uh journals uh which
I I think I actually think journals are
always a great gift to give somebody uh
they've got puzzles and Advent calendars
uh you can get your name or somebody
else's name uh on a snowflake ornament
uh it's just kind of cool stuff man and
it's Unique and uh it's it's artisan and
it's it's very very cool um when you
shop at Uncommon Goods you're supporting
this is important you're supporting
artists and small independent businesses
These Fine products are made often in
small batches so shop now before they
sell out this holiday season all right
Uncommon Goods looks for products that
are high quality unique and often
handmade uh or made in the US they uh
have the most meaningful and out of the
ordinary gifts out of anywhere so just
check them out you want 15% off by the
way you're going to get 15% off your
next gift when you go to
uncommongoods.com tastebuds that's
uncommongoods.com
tastebuds
taste buds for 15% off don't miss out on
this limited time offer Uncommon Goods
were all out of the ordinary Orville is
the king of human mascots but he's still
not touching Mr Peanut dude has a joke
where he goes if I again I'm not doing
the joke I'm not wording it correctly
but he has a joke that goes something
like I If I say to all of you right now
the words Mr Peanut you know exactly
what I'm talking about that's insane and
like that's true yeah you say to
somebody Miss P there's not a person on
Earth that goes who like it's it's at
Mickey Mouse almost a person in the
United
States what what pimp the average
European give me planter peanuts in
foreign countries the average the Aver
European eats less than one tablespoon
of peanut butter per year America
consumes enough to fill the floor of the
Grand Canyon in year okay well thank god
this show takes place in
America I mean you know uh but I mean
I'll tell you dude let's talk about this
let's talk about Christmas what can you
live with that we're owned by we're
owned by crap or we were owned by Hines
a that's just sales that's just all
right go ahead go ahead what were you
going to say let's talk about Christmas
what can you do with peanuts roasting on
an open fire what do you decorate the
tree with dude only if you're trash do
you put those popcorn strings on your
tree that's normal that's normal Middle
America you don't like Rosanne you don't
like the show Roseanne you don't like
the people of the street the
racist
chestnuts you can't even do peanuts on
Christmas by the way Roseanne the family
from Rosanne could not decorate the tree
with popcorn cuz her and that John
Goodman would have ate it right off the
tree John Goodman's skinny now I hate
skinny John Goodman I hate it I hate
skinny John Goodman why why did he do
that cuz he was gonna die yeah I love
John Goodman I hate skinny John Goodman
he was a good actor and I love Roseanne
and and you're right I I guess that's a
sort of rosan goes with go with
Christmas peanuts what's the peanuts
what's the Peanuts holiday I don't know
dude I I will tell you I'll tell you
right now is there peanuts is there a
holiday at all linked up with
Peanuts holiday is not linked to popcorn
that's a kitcheny jary 16 let tell you
let me tell you what popcorn even though
I made fun of it and said it was trashy
let me tell you what that is it's not
trashy it's the opposite it's what a
kitchy guy like it's like what Frasier
Crane would do Frasier Crane would
decorate Tree in different strains of
strands of popcorn oh you can dye it
it's lovely it's for the kids I I don't
know dude I don't know about that look
at that we got a peanut holiday in this
country a pocorn holiday too Friday the
13th brother next year oh [__] it's own
so listen here's the thing I promise you
this you see a bowl of nuts out at on a
Christmas holiday spread you're going to
you're not before you're going to see
popcorn but you will give popcorn as a
gift at Christmas okay let's talk about
this which is the shittiest gift it is
shitty that I would beat somebody to
death with if they give it that BR of
fruit I'd rather get a fruit cake than
than some popcorn even from Clarks you
ever get some like Clarks or nuts on six
or whatever like look like I could get
popcorn I just make some popcorn
somebody gives you a tin of three
flavored popcorns and they're like it's
it's a highend it's it's a Delux I
thought this would be fun for you and
you you and your girl to
you caramel and then you could try the
cheddar and
yeah oh and there's nothing worse to me
than a cheddar popcorn here's one I'm
going to give you I'm going to give you
for peanut okay and I don't like to
admit this
peanuts kill children and that makes me
happy well I was going to say nothing is
more there's no more weaponized food
than the peanut peanut will take down a
group of throw something at it you can
it can survive if popcorn touches water
it shrivels up like a slug popcorn can
by the way by the way I just thought of
a throw the gauntlet down argument point
that I made with my with my flavored pop
corn thing
yeah Hey pimp hey V what's in what's in
caramel corn what's in Cracker Jack it
ain't Just
Popcorn peanuts [__] they got to put my
food into your food to soup up your food
no no no they're putting it into your
food to soup it up no it's not called
caramel corn I mean peanuts caramel corn
what is
that caramel you know exactly what just
covered with caramel there's peanuts in
that candy corn not candy corn caramel
corn stop it you know what this is oh
there's added peanuts in it they add
they got to get rid of it they like
throw some in the caramel corn we can't
get rid of this [__] fast enough they're
like nobody wants this [__] no matter
what we cover it in well let's talk
about the movies you love movies do you
ever go to the movies and be like hey
give me a warm tip of of popcorn goers
of the movies chocolate covered peanuts
that's chocolate covered that's so we
said all flavors we said all flavors you
P that's covered so is your movie
popcorn it's covered in God knows what
it's soaked and by the way they can't
even call it butter they have to call it
butter flavor whatever that chemical
thing they're mixing in the back room is
you ever get the fat guys like it's real
butter at this theater like why is that
a of my face you fat
pig the are we talking about after skank
F we know D Roa prefers nuts not bad not
bad I know all right two two no I know
all last episode it's whatever it's
going to be a thing for a while B but uh
I wouldn't say prefer I think I'm on the
side that's right like don't mind nuts
it's different PR enjoy them too I enjoy
them in addition too um should we talk
about
campfires you're going to try to say
popcorn is a campfire food Jiffy Pop oh
stop it Ari well what's peanuts peanut
the C I'm not saying peanuts are a
campfire food either I'm saying popcorn
is not a campfire dude Jiffy Popco is a
stove top thing that's not a I mean I
guess some people bring it it was a
reach I'll give it to you no well let's
from the uh yeah it's started on that
you think wait talk on talk on the mic
so we can hear you wait no no keep
talking off the mic I like the I like
the far away sound you like that pimp
you have done it on a fire or it's like
a a thing you do like camping I've done
it yeah it's it's made for camping look
I've Al I've also uh uh uh you know
cooked Italian sausage on an open fire
when I'm camping I wouldn't say like
it's a thing you do this is the thing
show me pictures of campfire Jiffy Pop
you will find
something do they even make Jiffy Pop
anymore they do uh it burns quite fast
yeah it just seems like an insane boom
boom it seems like an yeah look at it
look at it just black it just gets black
it's so it never comes out good you
always forget and you rip the top off
and then you're like no you needed the
top I got to tell you Ari very few
pictures of Jiffy Popp on an open flame
here there's one there's one there's
there's some but I mean it's not well
let's see let's see the the peanuts on
an open flame but I'm I never said
peanuts worse well let's see sausage
sausage on an open flame I will tell you
this dude out of you you can you can
bring me any flavor of popcorn you want
even movie butter popcorn soaked in the
awesome butter flavor with the salt I
mean it's delicious it's delicious but I
will tell you this ain't nothing even
coming close to a honey roasted peanut
dude they put honey roasted peanut great
it's unhealthy times two you get honey
you're like why did they not have this
only I'm like get this away from me
right now and what is the what is the
process of Honey roasting is just
soaking in Honey and then cooking it I
don't know I don't know either it's
sugar it's salt and it's honey I'm just
like it's like brown sugar maybe yeah
pimp what are the ingredients you know
it's overrated kettle corn
popcorn wait what do you mean it's the
sweet popcorn corn that's the caramel
corn isn't it no no it's just like
coconut oil or something it's not it
doesn't touch a [__] honey see what
this recipe pimp keep scroll and it'll
eventually give us okay unsalted peanuts
honey butter chili powder garlic powder
and sugar wow I'm shocked that there's
no salt there's salt that's a different
salted peanuts oh that's like
healthy hone honey roasted peanuts are
honey roasted peanuts good for you no
oh my god dude they're so bad these when
I was when I used to ride for TV one of
the things in the room cuz craft
Services there would be a craft Services
room that was always loaded
with there were like staple snacks they
would go to it was weird like Red Vines
red I'm I'm not joking when I say this
Red Vines must have a contract with the
studios because Red Vines were the only
red licorice ever in the snack room when
you wrode on the for a TV show it was
always west coast East Coast but I was
like never Twizzlers ever they don't do
them there it was just weird embargo but
anyway so it's a Mississippi thing there
would always end up being a a vat of
honey roasted peanuts on the table in
the writer's room CU they would put
something out that every before covid
and everybody was afraid to do community
food they would just put and you were I
it was it was torturous it was torturous
because you're already sitting on your
ass for 9 hours and you're like the last
thing I need to do is start eating this
stuff guys they have it there say you're
going to gain can you go back to the
beginning and see how the guy gently
laid down that thing it's so unnatural
earlier before the
cup watch this guy watch this guy lay
down something right here watch watch
how slow peanut wait back up back up
back up look at that so unnatural that's
peanut brittle though that's not honey
roasted peanut they're calling peanut
ble honey roasted peanuts yeah that's
weird the way that that that's they're
not supposed to be all connected like
that I'm talking about the things in the
bag or in the tin can I tell you about
peanuts and their history
yeah is this real or is it like a thing
you made up real no this is real I did a
lot of research in the Uber over here
his name was not Ahmed but let's just go
with that um they were seen in the
beginning as a food for livestock poor
people and the enslaved okay common man
I like it mhm you know who likes you
know who likes popcorn who rich people
Epstein from Epstein's Island who was
his favorite wait was it really his
favorite let's say that yes no
George HW Bush his favorite was popcorn
he negotiated a he shook hands with
Gorbachev you know who likes wait HW
sorry H yeah wait was really was that
his favorite food popcorn yeah you know
who's you know Jimmy Carter's favorite
food is you know what he did ever not
suck George HW Bush did do people hate
him he did do a few impressive things he
ended he basically ended the Cold War
like he was responsible for it he
negotiate rack out of KU I was looking
it up and I was like oh I think he gets
a lot of bad Flack for his son he gets
tons of flack D he didn't he didn't he
help create the CIA or something it was
like wild he did some he was like he's
got some wild notches in his belt and
like and like people hate his gun and he
got unseated by a
full America was like ah I like the
peace deal with like this guy's fun
though you're like yeah but what about
the the things he did no who cares he
plays a sacks on Areno he's a good time
it's pretty good we should not be
allowed to vote president I have a
theory about presidents it's all about
who you would want to drink beers with
or not you don't want to drink beers
with George Bush no it's George W you do
George W you do I want to do that's why
that guy does panel on talk shows now
and everybody laughs and cheers for him
Trump will be doing panel on talk shows
in 5 years and people will be cheering
for him we missed you you were so good
you were so funny they yeah if I was s
with George Bush Jr and I was like hey
what's going on we were private I'd be
like hey can you find the good Coke and
he'd be like yeah you know I can dude I
met a guy once that's why everybody
loved Clinton you want to drink beers
with the guy that's why nobody knows any
they only remember the good stuff about
Obama cuz you want to kick it with Obama
you you're like gu seems like fun to
hang out with cool dog play C them I met
a guy once in I think in you can eat
more of popcorn that's a great point and
I got to say this you can eat popcorn
for an hour and a half while you're
binging Netflix late at night you can
just keep eating popcorn and you will
gain one qu of a pound that's not a good
thing they say the most peanuts you
should eat is 16 peanuts and then it
becomes
unhealthy that's less than a small pack
okay but I don't think that that's let
that sink in I don't I wouldn't want to
eat more than 16 peanuts [__] and by
the way that's also nonsense because we
eat peanut butter two a a normal helping
of peanut butter is more than 16 peanuts
it's got to be helping what's a helping
you know what a helping a peanut is one
tablespoon two tablespoons is the
serving size on the even fill up one
slice no no two tablespoons will fill up
a slice the recommended limit for how
many peanuts you should eat per day is
42 gram this is about 16 peanuts
anything more than that is unhealthy
okay I'm not eating peanuts every day
but my point is is if you make a PE it's
not it's 16 PS if you eat peanuts every
day that's like saying if you drink beer
every day you only eat peanuts you're
talking about peanut butter the only way
to eat peanuts is to completely change
its form make it a different thing but
I'm saying if you eat real peanut butter
you're eating more than 16
peanuts but you're not eating it every
day is my point I don't buy that that's
16 peanut I don't buy that that sounds
like I like how you argued against it
and then go actually I don't believe
those that I just don't if you eat two
spoonfuls of peanut butter a day you're
over your limit it's like you're going
to die right yeah that's not a healthy
thing to eat popcorn it's it's not I
don't think that that's a a bonus that
you could just keep eating you can and
it stops you from snacking I've talked
to multiple anorexic and a few bimix it
is popcorn as the healthiest I've got a
stomach ache from popcorn you never got
a stomach ache from it no you get a
stomach ache from your sudden lack of
junk food and your stomach goes uh I
need KFC please KFC at least churches or
Popeyes it's detox dude you can't just
stop heroin cold turkey of course you
get a little tummy
ache wait hold a second it's popcorn is
over 5,000 years old I'm telling you
something though dude what popcorn it's
way more fattening than you way no it's
only peanut butter fatting fattening is
the wrong word you will gain weight from
it more than you think you will it's
straight up carbs dude no it's not it's
fiber it's nothing there's nothing in it
it's so there's no carbs and popcorn
it's just it is it's fiber it's just why
they why do they tell you to avoid but
it's good fat then why do they tell you
to avoid corn if you're trying to not
eat carbs if you can just eat corn then
why 21 G 21 G it's a lot of carbs but
you burn it off it's no fat it's no fat
you burn it off 1 oz is 21 G now here's
the thing 1 oz is a lot of goddamn Park
how much much Fiers is in popcorn in a
serving
tons fiber good let's do net carbs here
okay you're not getting a lot of net
it's still heavy in net carbs man
dietary fiber is good isn't it I really
PE so bad I can't hold it is popcorn a
good fiber source Ari for the first time
ever in the history of taste buds I'm
giving the wheel to you to another to
person that's not me or S yeah you can
steer the ship for the next three
minutes while I pee Oh my god well I
mean I have so many pranks to please
don't do horrible okay just don't do
anything horrible just talk about the
food please okay that's all right all
right folks let's talk game time love
game time I love game time uh have you
ever had a frustrating ticket buying
experience I know I have when almost
every single time I've ever bought
tickets for anything uh I just I don't
like it uh I don't like buying tickets
in advance or far in advance at least um
I don't like trying to figure out what
it's going to look like from where I'm
sitting by just looking at some seat map
uh and I don't trust that I'm always
getting the best priced uh and these are
these are all the things you shouldn't
have to worry about when you buy tickets
for a big event all you should be
thinking about is how much fun you're
going to have at the event well this is
where game time comes in to allow you to
do that okay game time offers last
minute tickets Flash Deals Zone deals uh
they let you see what it looks like from
the seats where you'll be sitting seat
views uh it's easy to find and buy
tickets for every kind of event in your
area whatever it is and it's the lowest
priced guarantee uh there's event
cancellation protection there's job loss
protection I just really really like
game time making it easy for me to get
the tickets when I feel like getting
them which is late in the process uh and
knowing that I'm getting the best deal
possible so download the game time app
create an account and use code taste
buds for $20 off your first purchase
take the guess work out of buying
tickets with game time Again download
the app create an account use code taste
buds get $20 off your first purchase
terms apply but again create that
account redeem the code t a s Buu DS for
$20 off download game time today last
minute tickets lowest price
guaranteed folks this holiday season you
might be looking for nutritious
convenient meals to keep you energized
on those jam-pack days well that's where
Factor comes in Factor America's number
one ready to eat eat meal delivery
service they can help you fuel up fast
for breakfast lunch and dinner with Chef
prepared dietitian approved ready to eat
meals that are delivered where straight
to your door you'll save time you'll eat
well you'll stay on track all right get
that healthy lifestyle thing going keep
it going while you're tackling all the
holiday to-dos I know that during the
holiday season it gets very busy and I
know that those busy times in my life
are when I start to fall out of my Reg
and start to fall out of my good habits
well factors help me not do that and
they can help you not do that as well
all right don't let's also just point
out that the holidays are busy a lot of
us don't have the time to cook okay so
it's that's a factor too that the time
that this is saving you the stress that
this is alleviating so you don't have to
worry about the meal preps and all that
stuff you're going to be able to choose
from 35 Plus weekly flavor packed fresh
never frozen meals that support a
healthy LIF style and meet your meal
preferences and again all delivered to
you at your front door and they're ready
to eat in 2 minutes I love it I love it
I love it I love what factor is doing
when you're too busy running around to
plan lunch Factor has you covered with
lunch to go effortless wholesome meals
like grain bowls and salad Toppers
they're ready to eat when you're on the
go no microwaves even required for those
ones gosh they're doing it right and try
these delicious dietitian approved
calorie smart meals with a round or less
than 500 50 calories per serving all
right head toctor meals.com
tastebuds 50 and use code tastebuds 50
to get 50% off that's code tastebuds 50
at Factor meals.com
taste buds 50 to get 50% off yeah the
wrong side of History tour is on the
road is on the road right now get get
tickets on my site all right cool man
yeah go seei it's fun we should do what
we should do also our uh popping little
nuts in his mouth yeah yeah yeah you're
right that's [__] show uh here again I
mean the thing we did at skang Fest we
should do it here how was that it was
the highlight Norman said it was like
the his favorite show at skankfest yeah
uh a lot of comics liked it Adam uh Adam
from The the from Mothership said that's
the funniest show I've ever seen ever at
a festival the show was Ari and Joe talk
[__] about any comic you suggest or any
comic [__] on any comic you tell us to
yeah exactly uh and that's what it was
we we made sure all the phones are out
of the room and they're get bag for next
year to do it next year they're G to get
phone bags for that and the naked roast
next year yeah so we can really like not
worry about anything not worry at all I
want to do I want to do it here I want
to do one in New York I saw somebody
posted a picture of us all on stage
doing it she's like it's a picture I
know I shouldn't have have my phone out
I just blocked him good he's like I
didn't put any video I'm like you're
blocked you're done there was no phones
yeah good exactly uh and I reported the
police
I said there was illegal activity in the
area he downloading episodes of parks
and
wreck you know I got a warning from
Warner Brothers for illegally
downloading parks and W they had to say
what it is it was so embarrassing cuz
I'm like oh come on it couldn't have
been a movie you got me why were you
downloading parks and wreck parks and
wreck fan no it was like I mean I'm not
saying it's a bad show but it was like
it was one of the shows I watched so I
was like I downloaded everything just
illegally downloaded everything okay I
just felt like it was like I don't know
it's funny I would have thought you
would download something for like HBO
because you don't have the premiums or
something it was an NBC
show I yeah I didn't have cable so I
couldn't so you just watch later all
right well [__] man yeah the early days
of downloading were the best everything
and with a decent connection it was wild
and then one day somebody was like you
know you're in the entertainment
business right you shouldn't do that and
I was like oh yeah I guess you're right
dud literally my Netflix special aired
and I was watching it on with Big J's
password that I had stolen for years
entertainment industry who gives a I
just mean cuz it's taken away from the
artist stuff all right yeah good you're
fair enough you're right yeah you're
talking to a guy who legit regularly
shoplifts from om and Pops
[Laughter]
only yeah I hear you and I've also uh
slapped food that you've bought at my
bar out of your hand cuz I thought it
was funny so I I don't respect my own
income so yeah screw
it all right uh let's go to the phones
uh go to phones yeah oh it's a healthy
GMO free and
glutenfree snack that's key isn't
Popcorn gluten-free popcorn is
gluten-free I mean a peanuts God damn I
keep mixing my words it's not GMO
free what what's GMO again genetically
modified
Organics
peanuts
organisms
gluten-free okay well they both are yeah
uh well that means try one of the two
low risk of heart disease diabetes and
some cancers by eating
popcorn what are the health benefits
real quick pimp what are the health
benefits of of peanuts you know what
they're going to do give you the health
benefits in moderation which no one does
nobody but you got to eat popcorn in
moderation I'm telling you you e too
much popcorn you're going to put weight
on from the carbs do you ever have an
unsalted uh peanut peanuts are a great
source of fiber fiber is an important
thing thing popcorn's a better source of
fiber it's not we looked it up it's a
better source of fiber it's not it's
fiber peanuts to popcorn and then look
up yourn popcorn was a low source of
fiber that's why the neck carbs are so
high okay peanuts contains two times
let's see popcorn is more damn
it popcorn is more fiber while peanut
has more copper who needs copper in
their diet that's crazy only Jews are
looking for copper it's a Penny's joke
the amount of saturated fat in popcorn
is lower all right healthy wise it's
popcorn's way better I mean it's so much
I'm telling you all these Anor tell you
they they go too far but they got good
ideas going with popcorn solely because
of Jiffy po pop you can eat peanuts
whenever and wherever you want whereas
popcorn is limited that is a good point
peanuts do have a universal like take
them with you vibe that popcorn doesn't
have no exactly because you'll smush
you're right look at this idiot dis fat
[__] oh I get what you did there oh
that's funny I thought you called her I
was like why are you calling her a fat I
was like oh that's his handle neither
are enjoyable after a few handfuls like
who the this is so dumb who the is
finishing an entire bucket of popcorn at
the movies uh me everybody every single
time what are you talking I'm always
like why didn't they have an extra large
I finish it before the previews are done
I get it without butter at the movies
without butter I get it just like by the
way it's still has something on it it
tastes way too good and it's still
yellow for no reason right why would it
have a yellow if there no
it's made in butter there's extra has
something going on it's so good and when
you pass by you ever go to see a movie
just because you pass by and get that
smell only Subway does that where you're
like maybe maybe I'll just go in and get
some popcorn wa only Subway the smell of
Subway is gross no no they pump out
bread a gross smell though it's a bad
smell why did they pump it out on
purpose because dumb shits think it
smells good they don't know any better I
forgot Subway particularly uh attacks
you and your business mod it doesn't
attack me it's just gross I used to love
Subway I us to love stab in the back
like making a big boy what is what is
the 1937 World Series snack battle
that's what say this is an old one
people eat everything else a younger me
says popcorn but the 47-year-old me
teeth and gum say peanuts that's a great
Point dude what you don't go from
peanuts you do that with popcorn dude
those kernels get in your
throat have the worthless shell the
membrane in between the shell and the
other shell that their only job is to
make you be embarrassed on a date uh why
do you say that just gets in there it's
just that little brown off animal oh you
can take off each one each one each one
you buy them taken off or if it's at a
[__] game it gets in your teeth
that's another reason I like peanuts
better peanuts make you work a little
bit to get to the snack if you're eating
them traditionally whereas popcorn I
can't tell how many times I watch people
just like go just shovel their faces
full of popcorn you're like it's like
popcorn's a food where you watch
somebody eat it and you're like you
disgust me go on the other room like
Jesus God you know like kettle corn
caramel corn cheese corn what do you eat
you never eat peanuts at a movie only
gooboo only if it's covered and and who
honestly eats that even rare a one in
eight P person yeah but this this is
this guy I love this you know how many
kinds of Pop cream there are and then he
names three there are that many kind
caramel cheese and that's it yeah
there's there's there's that many kinds
of peanuts too butter he forgot butter
popcorn is tied to Cinema Live sports
memories pean dude guys peanut is tied
to live the guy walking around with the
hot peanuts at the games throwing them
out to people it is way more tied to
Live Events than than popcorn is no it's
only baseball should have gone Popcorn
versus potato chips well we didn't well
you should have chosen a different path
in life popcorn all the way I think you
might take this dude where's the peanut
Galler when you what am I two and0 or
three and0 I know I got I know I got
salami you won the cereal one and I won
the cereal one she so you're at least
two and I'm two and0 and I don't want to
break my streak Molly says don't really
like either but I'd have to lean towards
popcorn you also did the hot chip
challenge on here and that killed a kid
they recalled all those really yeah they
it killed it's insan I can't loser I did
it and I added hot sauce you dumb dead
loser hey the parents are that The
Grieving parents I say don't even start
over because your jeans areed oh boy all
right I don't know if that'll be in the
episode or not they're probably old
parents who dies from a Hot Chip what we
mean a kid die unless somebody stabed
the eye with it I'm shocked I I I've
been shocked from the jump at how hot
foods are getting like like like we'll
call them Pharmacy Foods meaning like
chips you can buy at like CVS or
whatever like when they say habanero now
in the bag they're truly hot now it
didn't used to be like that it used to
be like which ones the what I'm saying
like I'm calling them like Pharmacy
foods like meaning like you go down the
snack aisle at a CVS and you can get
chips that say like habanero oh yeah the
ghost pepper ones they're they're truly
hot now it's when you eat a lot on
lights you up yeah I'm shocked at like
how hot that food has become before it
used to be like hot reminiscent us team
dies after eating the spicy viral chip
challenge okay here's why journalism is
in a terrible place is cuz they put in
words to make you believe saying it's
not true it says a US team dies in
massachus from in the US tragically died
last Friday but I don't believe it is
tragically that's an opinion work I
think it's justifiably died and that's
why this journalism is not to be
believed hours after eating a chip
dusted with the rest of facts Carolina
Reaper the Naga Viper sure sure TR Naga
Viper Naga Maga Mega magga n America
great the uh but no I'm shocked that
like you can just readily buy that's
wild to me like like especially with the
with the categorization of ghost peppers
hold on yeah which uh this this lady
makes a great you bite an actual G Eddie
if bit a ghost pepper on his podcast
like as a goof and like almost had to go
to the emergency room yeah it's he was
like dude it put me on like the floor I
couldn't like it's bad I had no problem
with that
chip it was just like spicy for sure you
had a little bit of like but like you
got through it yeah but I wasn't like do
you think you could bite a ghost pepper
no I don't want to do that that's
legitimately like I you much I think
these flavored ones are like a a step
down do you ever watch the man versus
food where he eats like the hottest
curry in all of like New York and like
dude he's eating and he's like it's like
literally looks like he's going to have
like a stroke or something you ever go
to jit Lada jit l a terrible name for a
place yeah you hate Thai people but like
uh yeah it's jit it's like macari's
favorite place it's spicy TI Southern
Thai food and when they order something
and you're like how do you want it like
low spice High spice or Thai spicy like
Thai spicy and they go hey man do you
understand that it's like legitimately
spicy if you do that and they go they go
yeah sure and they come first with a
thing of carrots and and uh and um
cucumbers on a bed of ice just to have
these to soak it up it's it's so hot way
hotter than that chip like how hot it's
just like on another level it just
lights you up
like a point where you feel like I'm
going to pass out I feel I'm going to
huc you get lightheaded the sweat under
the eye starts and you really get
lightheaded the uh well dude that's like
uh in Indian restaurants where they put
the numbers next to the
food like you could go to right exactly
you go to a nice Indian restaurant and
the menu will still look like you're in
a Burger King cuz there's numbers on it
next to the thing and it's because they
have to tell you how hot the food is you
know what I want them to and they tell
you don't go above like an eight don't
go why do you make it that way yeah yeah
I used to have to get my CH my Chinese
roommate to order um spicy Chinese form
me or they wouldn't do it he need the
accent wait what they would at Universe
of Maryland I would order like spicy got
a legit extra spicy and they wouldn't do
it and then when he ordered for me they
would do it like on the phone yeah why
would you just do his accent and
just what you just do a racist acent
just get the food I feel like that's
well within your wheelhouse of something
you would do it was early I hadn't
developed into who I was
yet all right this lady made a good
point um whatever her name was uh Monica
or something she goes you know what it's
for you you know what's fun with peanuts
putting them in your hand shaking them
and eating them that's a fun thing she's
saying that because sa no matter what
food we pick he always goes you put some
in your hand you shake them around you
whatever he says that a lot and I it
makes me crazy that he says that D well
that lady made a good point but today it
works for me it is
true uh are we ready for wait wait wait
wait wait so hold on hold on hold on
hold on let me let me let me let me let
me get ready for this let me get ready
for this so we're going to see now who
your plugs first okay do your plugs um
because we're going to wrap it up I'm on
the road I'm at the Palace of Fine Arts
like I said all over the Midwest oh you
already did them all right never mind
yeah and then uh I don't know wrong side
of History tour it's it's everywhere all
right cool uh all right ready go ahead
what you were going to say I you're
going to win think I 100% can tell you
right now you're going to win worried
there was almost zero from what we saw
Pro peanut comments so unless it's
another silent sleep uh uh uh sleeper
silent winner uh Sleeping Giant that's
what I was looking for uh which we've
had a few of those in recent months but
peanuts is more American I'm surprised
but uh let's let's see it let's see show
me popcorn
y
wow 78 78.8 popcorn takes it to crushing
21.2 almost tripled the amount of votes
you got all right dude you have to say I
still love you I don't though that
implies an early love all right good
show taste buds they com to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools going
to fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they coming to the